Well, the intention of this lesson is to introduce you to the topic of software
architecture. That we're going to be looking at in more detail in subsequent
lessons. The ultimate goal of course, is to produce high quality systems and
reduce the cost of producing them. The key way of doing that is the early
detection of problems. And the key way of detecting things early is to
try to layout in advance, what the, what the system is going to look like.
You want to have explicit recognition of what the issues are, explicit rationale
for how they are being handled. We want to be able to on the productivity side
to deal with any existing assets we can apply toward the solution. And
we want to be able to construct an architecture at a sufficient level of
abstraction. That it can be used to convey all these idea quickly and
effectively to all the stakeholders involved.